all right man I've already I've stopped
a bunch of those football players all
right stop Darnell Washington and I just
stopped Dylan Fairchild
I just stopped Washington didn't stop
yesterday
uh Fairchild just stopped like a minute
ago he's going 70 right here
I don't need to slow down dude
I had to take a picture of your VIN okay
is your name pulling up because it's a
dealer tag
[Music]
so I got it
all right man
gotta crack your window okay
a little little
a little bit more brother rather I don't
want you to jack it all over okay all
right so this has just been calibrator
okay so there's a test meter in the car
it's 24 to register 24 so in Georgia the
darkest it can be is 29 so it's 32
percent plus or minus three so the
darkest it can be 29 all right all right
yeah you're at five my man so what limo
10 I guess is that what you got
so the other thing is in Georgia this
windshield the front windshield can't
have nothing on it no material on it
whatsoever okay
yeah so all right man just hang tight
your breakage you're not going to jump
that's your break because I'm going to
make all kinds of news right
all right it's the same time look you're
gonna take it for the speed all right
now catch yourself doing something that
not smart I'll use that word
and I catch other things you're getting
attacked on with that and then that okay
so the breakage you ain't going to jail
okay
you can probably win it but okay
are they advising that their alarm is
through Ackerman because all right look
I don't know
y'all need to send out a taxes online
so how your teammates
I could care less about 10 bucks what
are you doing something dumb stupid like
that but almost stack stuff on you but
the break is you ain't going to jail
because I was I was Reckless all right
so when you we're going around your
teammates just tell them to slow down
that is so easy to just slow down all
right so all right look the court dates
October 31st at 9. due to the speed you
might have to show up I don't know but
there's a phone number on your copy you
can call it and ask to ask if they want
you to it they don't want you to you can
just take care of this online all the
directions are on your pockets okay
so each X that represents an infraction
okay so the moving in fractions of speed
so that's your first X by signing the
first off by signing this is not a
mission to go just letting the court
know you're going to take care of it
that's all that means okay first one is
the speed for 89 and 45 the second one
it's an equipment violation okay so uh
for the window tint the third one is an
equipment violation it's the windshield
each one is separate okay so that that's
in its own category as a windshield this
was in its own category okay so do a
little sign your name like I said it's
not a mission to build all right
all right man here's your license and uh
your copy you got you have any questions
slow down okay that's all I asked all
right
uh I don't know if they're going to wrap
this all up into one thing if not yeah
you can just take care of it online
but uh yeah if I were you I'd call the
phone number that's that's on there and
ask if they want you to show up or not
okay
all right drive safe man 45.